[Music]
at what point does pet stewardship
exceed minimalist principles well let's
talk about what do you mean by
minimalist principles when ryan and i
are talking about lifestyle minimalism
which is different from minimalism in
literature or architecture or art
although they have a lot of
commonalities what we're really talking
about is getting rid of anything that is
excess right so if you have
excess in your life then i probably
wouldn't start adding more into your
life meaning okay well you know i bought
all this stuff
the average american household has 300
000 items in it i bought all of it it
didn't make me happy so you know what i
need some pets right well now you're
gonna not only be discontented with all
the stuff you have in your life but
you're gonna be discont you're gonna
make your pets discontent because you
don't have any other resources to
actually take care of them
and so
pets can be a tremendous blessing a joy
but if we are accumulating them the same
way we're accumulating stuff
then they too are going to be a burden
right
gosh yeah i mean that's a and it's a
double-edged sword right i mean
according to a lot of data out there you
know that first of all that connection
is is really important you bring in a
dog
like you had just mentioned because you
are collecting a whole bunch of things
these 300 thousand items don't satisfy
you and maybe bringing a dog in there
you might not think that's detrimental
to the dog but there's a lot of data to
show that a if the if
your connection between you and your dog
is severed or if there's that stress
factor that goes on between you and your
dog where um you know there's
nothing at home seems to satisfy you
you're a hung out you're strung out
you're a stressful individual there's an
italian study that shows that you can
actually grow a tumor on your dog with
that type of mentality wow so like
collecting animals to try to bring
yourself
happiness is
gosh it'd be hugely detrimental not only
to to to yourself but also to your dog
well and regret
regret is a powerful
thing in the animal space and most
animal lovers end up with some level of
regret oftentimes
because we
look back and say if i would have known
then what i know now i would have
navigated my dog's well-being
differently i would have made different
choices i wish i had more money to feed
better food i wish i wasn't working an
eight-hour job that i hate because i'm
having my dog in a crate is driving me
crazy
regret
causes people to have unbelievable open
wounds with their animals for forever
potentially
and one of the reasons that we did write
this book is to help people
identify what they can be doing
preemptively so that they don't have to
deal with regret regret is overwhelming
enough that it can scar and damage you
to the point that some people say i
don't want any i love animals
and they're amazing animal stewards and
guardians they're great people and
any shelter animal would be
they'd win the lotto going into these
people's beautiful lives because they
will solely focus on them but the human
has been so damaged from not having the
knowledge the tools the resources from a
previous pet that they didn't feel they
served appropriately and they can't bear
to do it again they can't get over the
guilt of a previous animal
and that's powerful and we part of the
reason that we wrote this book is so
many people said to us
i just want a blueprint i don't know how
to proactively or intentionally create
well-being i don't i don't know what
foods i should be feeding i don't know i
know that i want to create a good life
for my dog but i don't necessarily know
how to think about
uh my dog's life from his perspective
how do i do that
and so
much of this book is a blueprint for
people that are confused to provide
clarity for people that want to do
what's best but they don't necessarily
know for people that are burned from the
marketing hype or don't really know
where to turn to get the information
they need knowledge becomes a very
empowering tool
to be able to make decisions that allow
you to relax in
to enjoying
life
moment to moment with the animal that
you've signed up with how do i want to
ask you guys a question is as
professionals when it comes to
minimalism
i was on your social media page the
other day and i did see a comment in
there from a pet parent that said
and ryan you'll probably
be the best to go with this
having a pet
does not make you a minimalist meaning
if you want to be a minimalist you
should not have a pet you're not
practicing minimalism if you have a pet
so as a cat owner how would you come
back
at let's say that comment uh well i tend
to not argue with people online
but you know it's funny because you're
like as professionals but man we're the
minimalists because the domain was
available for seven bucks
and you know when i saw minimalism it
was about living intentionally which i
was not doing at the time it was about
using my resources and really
understanding the true cost of the
things that i was bringing into my life
and i think that's where uh and you
alluded to it earlier karen about people
don't really consider the cost there's a
financial cost but then there are all
these other costs associated with the
time attention like there are other
things that we have to be
uh very deliberate with to make sure we
have to to kind of take care of these
pets so um you know what i would say to
that specifically is
uh we would have to talk about what the
definition of minimalism is because i
think when people hear that word you
know you ask tenant for people what
minimalism is you're probably gonna get
10 different answers
but it's really just about living
intentional so can you live intentional
with the cat sure you sure can can you
live um unintentional with a cat yeah
you sure can um you could also live
intentional with thousands of dogs if
you have the room for them like i was
talking about earlier um which a piece
of me really aspires like to i don't
know about thousands of dogs yeah well i
mean no one owns thousands of thousands
of arms no no i'm talking about the i'm
talking about the rescue shelter the
rescue shelter in mexico were like she
had 500 acres yeah yeah as a rescue
shelter and
i think the point you're making here is
so if we talk about what is minimal
minimalism is the thing that gets us
past the things so we can make room for
life's most important things which
aren't things at all and so when we talk
about living intentionally
it's right there in the title of your
book the forever dog if you're going to
be intentional about bringing a dog or a
cat or a goldfish into your life
it's forever meaning the rest of their
life is the way we need to think about
it not what resources is going to take
from me today what kind of joy is this
going to bring me immediately but what
is the complete picture i'm going to
have this dog for the next five 10 15 30
years
and so i need to plan accordingly
because if i don't then i'm not making
an intentional decision and that is not
being a minimalist about it but if
minimalism is too stark of a word then
you can just say intentionalism yeah and
so what would an intentionalist do they
would think about the resources they're
going to have to expend on bringing this
pet in over the course of its entire
life because if you're prepared for that
and you still say yes to it you say hell
yes i still want this pet well then
you're making an intentional decision
yeah and you have to uh go into this
loving unconditionally
and i believe that that's one of the
biggest challenges that animals provide
to us
because
you maybe didn't know that you were
going to sign up to love a semi-feral
kitty
and that's beautiful but you also have
just accepted mac as being life on max
terms like if he wants to be touched
today cool and if not you're cool with
that but what if all you wanted was a
snuggle kitty you did not get inherit a
snuggle oh no
but if you had your mindset on listen i
want a kitty to hold and kiss him
yeah i want to cuddle with a thousand
puppies
but you are doing your job loving your
semi-feral cat anyway and that is what
we are called if we bring an animal in
and we say i'm going to sign up for this
animal forever
you are going to love
the warts and bumps and and habits and
the personality that develops in that
animal yeah you may say oh it's exactly
what i wanted and you may say oh not
what i expected wow
this is a high maintenance dog or cat i
love you anymore and that's right but i
will love you anyway and that also helps
us grow as humans that's huge you know
it's interesting we uh we had like a
game night um when my wife and i first
moved in together we did a game night
had a bunch of friends over and i was
talking about the cat and how the cat
was not a cuddly cat how didn't really
like me and one of my friends she was
like you know maybe mac was brought into
your life to help you with uh with
certain lessons and what lessons can you
learn from this kitty and that really i
mean that resonated with me because i
was like oh yeah like i am
mr like let me come up to you and and be
rough with you on betcha and
it's like but not everybody wants that
and so yeah like i that's exactly what
i've done is i've kind of um used him
instead of like trying to force him into
being a cat that i wish he was it's more
about me
kind of adapting to the type of cat he
is and i really have learned a lot from
that cat believe it or not
did you enjoy this stand-alone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free